[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today and
Hannah's going to kick us off in acran
Ohio this hour Hannah welcome to the
show hi thanks for having me sure what's
going
on so I am 22 uh my boyfriend's 23 and
my question is all of our debt will be
paid off by April of 2025 that's credit
card two vehicles and um yeah credit
card Vehicles all we have left will be
our new mortgage we just acquired last
year but our problem is our house is
sitting on land that's not in our name
so should I stay on our plan to pay
everything off now in 2025 or keep that
extra money start piling into a savings
to put a down payment on the property by
this next year so you're looking to buy
the
land yes how did that not happen with
the sale of the house when you guys
bought the house what was the so the
original the original deal was that me
and my boyfriend were looking for a
house we couldn't get approved for a
house by itself so we bought a modular
home and my grandma said oh you can put
it on my property um and then you guys
can eventually when you can buy the
property and keep it in the family name
okay cool so we did that um and she has
just been letting us have it here so
it's not just some SM Joo that we have
it on it is family sure however she
needs to get out of her debt that she
has on the property so ideally we don't
want to cut her short on buying the
property just to pay off what she has
but we also want to give her a fair
price for it so we've been here for
about a year we can financially I think
buy it by end of next year but I don't
know if I should stockpile all my extra
I'm putting into paying off my credit
card and our two vehicles okay or put it
towards a down payment okay um can we go
like a little high level conversation
here Hannah for for a second yeah um
okay so when you are talking about your
finances with your boyfriend you're
using a lot of like we statements we're
doing this our debt all of it so just
doing this for as long as we have um
when you are not legally
married there is not an
hours we conversation it's a Hannah's
conversation and what's your boyfriend's
name Joey
Joey yes and Joy's
money right so like like these there's
going to be two separate Lanes here and
I know that's going to be difficult for
you to kind of un tangle in your head
because it has been so unified but what
ends up happening is is that you combine
emotionally acting like you're married
combining accounts uh paying on each
other's debt all of it without any legal
representation no legal documents here
that if something happens I I'll say if
um that it's a complete mess and our job
is to be there for the people when it's
a complete mess so those are a lot of
the calls and some of the the stories
that we hear on that side so what I have
learned is as separate as you can live
that could be financially physically all
the things like as separate as you can
live until you're married it is it is a
cleaner break there there there is
something about it that that it just
makes it cleaner on an emotional and
financial side so I'm going to ask you
Hannah how much do you bring in with
your job what do you make 50,000 you
make 50,000 okay how how how cards do
you do you have any do are any of your
credit cards have his name attached to
them at all or are they just are their
credit cards with just Hannah's
name just the credit card that's in my
name he has his own that his he pays so
how much how much do you have in your on
your in your credit card how much debt
do you have on your credit card 2400
2400 okay perfect and then you have a
car is it just under your name one of
the cars yes okay and how much do you
owe on that one 5,000 5,000 perfect okay
and what does Joey make a year 880,000
880,000 perfect and what does um uh for
his credit cards how much does he
owe only like a thousand a thousand
perfect and what about his
car 29 29 truck 29,000 okay perfect okay
cool okay so what I would do Hannah is I
would be working to pay your using your
5050 K to be paying off your credit card
you paying off your car and he's working
his plan you can do it at the same time
but I would not be mixing numbers and
you guys have your own plan now the
mortgage is it in both your
names it is we have to do it that way to
get approved yes because you guys can't
you couldn't afford it otherwise so
right um okay so that's done so my next
piece of advice then would be
to if if you decide on your own Hannah
to put to to buy this property which I
don't think you can afford right now
with on your grandmother's property I I
I don't I don't see that happening soon
and if I were Joey I would not be tying
my name into land deeds and loans and
all of it with a family loan that on a
family property that I'm not I'm not
legally bound to like he's the one in
honestly Hannah he'd be the one that
gets screwed in this whole situation if
you guys break up um so my next thing
would be are y hope not it's been eight
years are y'all do what I said I hope
not it's been eight years yeah Hannah
and y'all are 22 and 23 I'll be honest
with you the the only reason we're not
married is because we don't have the
funds to do that Hannah Hannah Hannah
wrong answer you're telling me you had
the funds to get a mortgage but not to
get married Walmart and buy a silver a
silver bands go on Amazon I can go right
now on Amazon and get you guys two rings
for
$9.99 you go to the cor house and get
married go get married do it I've said
that but it's not good enough it's not
special enough Joey for him or for you
for him he's making excuses you guys are
acting like you're married anyways so
what does it what do what does a
certificate do it didn't change it that
much he wants to become a real estate
Mogul with you but not put a ring on
it he's making excuses he's heard it
from both sides my dad and okay let me
just tell you this I okay you should be
glad Rachel's on this call because I am
my blood is boil Geor you can add in I
just your life is like a common core
math problem it's so messed up it hurts
my brain you guys got yourself into a
mess and you're digging a whole Deeper
by getting entrenched in Grandma's
financial situation taking on land debt
on top of a mortgage that's in both of
your names but you're not married to
help Grandma out right
yeah did you hear how crazy that
sentence
was I know and I know it was a crazy
situation how about this how about we
back out of this land deal cuz we can't
afford it and we're 22 trying to figure
out our life I think we get out of this
modular home number one that modular
home is going down in value it's not a
great investment anyways so I would get
out of that thing as soon as you could
good luck finding another renter for it
right yeah that was kind of from the
beginning of why happen but we have to
think about the future when we make
decisions today and I really pray that
we can resolve this that you guys can
get out of this mess that you get
married that you step foot uh get on the
right foot with this thing but right now
I'm contining with this deal no you
can't you can't afford it Hannah you
can't afford it and it's not your
responsibility either in this so I would
find yeah separate those finances you
guys work your plan tell Joey to go on
Amazon I can send them a link and it
I'll send them a link